cross
validation in machine learning my name
is richard kirschner with the simply
learn team that's www.simplylearn.com
get certified
get ahead what is in it for you
we're going to cover the need for cross
validation
what is cross validation steps in cross
validation and types of cross validation
and then of course we'll do a nice
hands-on demo so you can see what it
looks like in python code
let's start by exploring the need for
cross validation
while choosing machine learning models
we need to compare models to see how
different models perform on our data set
this goes beyond just comparing
different models
but also in explaining this to the
shareholders or whoever you're working
with
you really need to know how valid is
your data set
or your models that you're working with
on the data set so
the need for cross validation comes up
when the data is usually limited
and training and testing on the same
portion of data does not give us
an accurate view of how our model
performs
and this just makes sense if i'm going
to program a model
to out guess something i don't want to
use the same data i trained it with
i want to see how it performs on the
next data
otherwise i'm just kind of like giving
myself my own juice saying hey my model
did really good because
this is what it was based on
self-fulfilling prophecy
and that is still important to do
because you still need to run it on your
own data to see
how well your set fits your data
versus how well it fits new data coming
in so training a model in the same data
means that the model will eventually
learn well for
only that data and fail on new data this
is called
overfitting so you might write a
wonderful script
it works great for predicting the
failure on loans for a bank
but it only works for the data you
already have not the new data coming in
and that again is overfitting so it's
not going to give you a proper you're
not going to get a good value as to how
good your model is going to fit the new
data coming in
so what is cross validation cross
validation is a technique
which is used to train and evaluate our
model on a portion of our database
before re-portioning our data set and
eventually
it using it on the new portions
consider the block shown to be our
complete data set
and you can see we've already taken the
data set and divide it into four
sections and here we've cut out one
section highlighted in yellow
we partition the data set into training
and testing
data and you'll see that in this
particular example we've taken 75
percent of the data or three quarters of
it
and we said okay we're going to use that
to train our model
and the testing data set will be used by
our model to predict
on unseen data it is used to evaluate
our model's performance
and this is what we were talking about
is you want to be able to train it on
one set of data
come back and say hey this is how well
it performs on data it's never seen
before
now there's an interesting relationship
between these
and it's important to also see how well
it performs on the train data
we're not going to talk about too much
on that one it's usually used in
higher end neural networks and it's one
of the ways they know when the training
data is done
and the testing data and the predictions
kind of match
that's when they start looking at okay
you've trained it enough
and you can see here we take the first
partition and we go ahead
and we map how good it did and we
partition the data set into training and
testing data
we then choose a different portion of
the data for training
and testing and re-evaluate the model
performance
to get more accurate results and you can
see here we've colored it in a nice
pretty yellow for you
and so we've tested on the first section
and now we're testing it on the second
section
so we're still using three quarters of
the data to
train our our model and one quarter to
test it
and we just loop through all the
different quarters to test it
that's what we're talking about we talk
about cross validation is we want to be
able to get a picture of how it works on
the data it hasn't seen and we look at
the steps in cross validation
the steps involved in cross validation
begin with step one
split the date into train and test sets
and evaluate models performance
as we measure one we measure two
we measure three and we measure four
and each one of these generates its own
performance rate based on the other 75
percent being used
to validate that data how well does it
perform on the unseen data
and so we have actually created four
separate models
and then we just take those measurements
uh one two three four we add them
together divide by four
or however many divisions you use and
you get a total model performance
for myself when i first start doing a
new data set
i'll start with just partitioning it
into three because it runs faster it's
quick
you only have to run three models that
kind of set up
a lot of this depends on how much data
you have if you have a lot of data three
works just fine
if you're very limited on how much data
is coming in you might want to divide it
into more
uh validation sets when you're first
testing out your models and your data
sets
and there's other steps in here we'll
look at in just a moment types of cross
validation now this is important because
we looked at one type
it's actually we're going to put down as
a number two type
one of the ways we can do this is what
they call leave one out cross
validation this is where the entire data
set is used for training
and one singular data point is kept as
the testing data
consider a data set with n points n
minus one will be training set at one
point will be testing set
leave one out cross validation is then
we go to another point
and it'll be chosen as a testing data
and the rest of the points will be the
training
this will repeat for the rest of the
data set in times
and yes we're creating if your data is
in well they used
n minus 1 in so we'll do it n minus 1
times
and you create n minus 1 models that
you're testing across your data set to
see how good your model does
the final performance measure will be
the average of the measures for all in
iterations and so you add up all those
different measures and divide by
n minus 1. now keep in mind at the end
you just run it across all the data and
that's your final model that you're
going to actually push out
this is to validate it this gives it an
n minus one validation
you can imagine if you're dealing with
big data and you have terabytes of data
doing it this way would probably be a
very bad idea
you might have to wait a month before
you get an answer where dividing it into
smaller portion works
so again we're dealing with smaller
amounts of data usually
when you do this level of
cross-validation
k-fold cross-validation this is what our
example initially was and this is what
most people look at is you divide it
into in this case four sections
so the data is divided into k number of
different sections
and like i said i like to use three if
i'm just initially looking at the data
it gives a decent training model versus
a faster run so at least i know i'm
using
66.66 percent of the data
one section is for testing and the rest
for training the number of sections k
is a selected depending on size of data
set
again if you have a very small data set
you want your k to be much larger
because you just you really can't divide
out most your data
you lose so much in the training and so
if you divide it out enough you end up
with
leave one out cross validation we divide
it all the way to each data point gets
its own run
and this will generate if we do k k
equals five
it will generate five different models
for you to evaluate on
and so of course we're generating each
one the final performance measured will
be the average of the output measures of
the k
iterations so we add them all together
and we divide by
k so we're gonna have five models
there's gonna be five measurements
and we'll divide that by five and that
gives us a good
guess you know good estimate of what the
measure is on this particular cross
validation going on
and how good our model is and then you
train the model with all the data in the
end
because you don't want to leave one
section out now
one of the things and i'm going to point
that out on this page before we get into
the next validation
what happens if your measurements are
all over the board you've divided into
five sections
one measurement is really bad one is
really good
that means there's something going on
with the way you divided your
data and how the data is set up and we
want to start looking at
stratified k-fold cross-validation
the data is split so that each portion
has the same percentage of all the
different classes that exist
in the data set consider a data set
which has
two classes of data as shown in normal
cross validation the data
is divided without keeping in mind the
distribution of
individual classes the model thus cannot
properly predict for minority classes
and you could think of this in that if
you were let's say
you had data set that was looking at
drivers how good do drivers do when
driving their car
and one of the features is the color of
the car now my guess it probably
wouldn't have a huge
impact as far as the data but let's face
it there's the most common car out there
is probably white there's probably brown
um when you get into like fire engine
red it
only has a few red cars
at that point if you train your data on
only cars that aren't red
you're going to run into a problem when
the red car comes up because it might
have one model that says
red cars are bad drivers or one model
that says red cars are good drivers
and at that point it's going to weigh
the data and create a bias so you need
to divide up
all those different features this comes
out
extremely heavily in doing
population statistics where we might
pull an
area out run the statistics but because
we're basing
our statistics just on that area and the
people they live in there
that area might be predominantly one
group of people and then you have a
minority
that is part of that group but there
there's a bias
as far as how they fit into the data and
how it weighs their particular choices
and then you start running into problems
with the bias on there that's why
using stratified k-fold cross-validation
is a very important thing to add into
your toolkit when you start looking at
the different data structures and
validating your models
stratified k-folds overcomes this by
maintaining the same percentage of data
classes in all the folds
models can be trained even on minority
classes
and you can see here where even though
we have five separate
uh splits in the data we used k equals
five
each one has a representation of all the
different features in there
so that we help get rid of that bias and
help each one train
equally across the data choose from over
300 in-demand skills and get access to 1
000 plus hours of video content for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description
to know more so with that let's roll up
our sleeves
we're going to do a demo where we use
adult census data to predict whether a
person is making above 500 000 a year
i'm going to go out on a limb and guess
that that is not
u.s money because that's a half a
million dollars in the u.s
but it's still a good money then we use
cross validation on our model to see
which one is performing better who is
earning less than 500k
that is the question we're going to ask
here for our demo
we're going to be using python3 which
you can use in whatever
ide you want i myself am going to be
using anaconda
notebook which opens up a nice web page
and from here we'll just go ahead and
create ourselves a new data set
for our new python scripting page
and we'll start by bringing in our
different modules in here
and you'll see in here let me go ahead
and change this to ah red's fine
that will go with black we'll see up
here at the top we have
our pandas and numpy this is your numpy
array and your pandas data frame
which we always like to use because they
look so nice and easy to use and view
and of course down here here's our
data frame here we're going to load up
our data and take a look at it in just a
minute
and then from our sk learn module
which you can see on the next set of
lines here we have our logistic
regression model
k neighbors classifier and then
our cross val score stratified
fold k-fold train test split and k-fold
and so this is really um what we're
looking at right here we're looking at
how to uh validate our different models
and it looks like we're going to be
doing this in logistic regress
regression and k neighbors classifier so
we can have something to compare on
there
and then of course once we have done
this we need to go ahead and have some
data so we'll go ahead and run this
here's our data set uh and this is
actually let's see we're using pandas so
this is a data frame
and then the first thing we're going to
look to see if we have any null values
i always check your data and see what
you have coming in you just never know
and so we can see here with with our
quick
data set dot is null and summit that we
have zero null values in our data set
so we've read our data set in and the
first step in any data
is always to take a look at it so we'll
take our data set
and we'll go ahead and do dot head now
remember
in jupiter notebook if this was
not the only line or the last line of my
code on this particular
grouping of cells i'd have to add print
around it
otherwise it just automatically prints
it for us and we can see here
here's our actual data and so we have
of course a nice you know the titles up
here age work class
different information education
i guess what level of education marital
status
relationship not in family race sex
capital
game capital loss and if you remember
correctly i talked a little bit about
social minorities imagine if you were
someplace where the predominant area is
all
in india someplace where everybody's in
is indian and there's a small group of
people who are what they call
expatriates who came from america
and happened to be white well you're
going into a problem we did that
cross-validation because if we're
looking at this
we might notice that or in this case uh
this
is just looking at the first four things
we see
three people who are white one person
who's black this might be a huge
discrepancy in our data and we want to
make sure we split that out or take a
look at that
we probably won't get into that too much
today but just be aware that this is the
kind of thing that you want to start
flagging yourself
on and it might be here we have work
class
private i'm not sure what that means
there's a lot of question marks here
that's kind of important to note also
and these are just some of the things i
start to look at when i look at this
data on here
native country united states so these
are people coming from the united states
and here's our 50 000. now remember
we're looking for five hundred thousand
um so the average person here is
probably around fifty thousand
maybe we'll take a look at that and see
what kind of uh
spread we have on our data but it's a
good place to start
and we'll go ahead and do this as a
print head
10. the reason i wanted to do that is so
we could take just a little closer look
at some of the data we're looking at
and if we go up here let's put a drawing
on there
let's take a note here under sex
we're talking about that probably
convert that to zero
and one and we're going to drop a lot of
these columns
uh on here maybe we'll also just look at
marital status
we might want to convert this to zero
and 1 on here
some other things that we're not looking
at is of course race
and this kind of gets interesting
because when you look at race
they only show right now i only show the
two variations we look at how many
variations there are
same thing with male and female if we
label one of these
zero and one one is not greater than
zero
and zero is not greater than one what
that means is that this is a yes
no but as we get more variety you can't
do that you can't do it yes
no you have to start splitting that up
into multiple columns
and again it depends on your data and
what you find out you might come in here
like we have marital status
we'll actually look a little deeper
marital status a couple different
options in here one is just to convert
this to married or not married that's a
zero one
we might split this into columns where
widow would be
zero one divorce would be 0 1 separated
0 1 and so forth
again it depends on what kind of data
we're looking at and how deep we want to
get into it
so let's go ahead and clean up our data
a little bit here
let's start by cleaning up a few columns
and again we're going to drop a bunch of
these because we don't want to spend too
much
time cooking our data and getting it all
set up correctly
we just want we want a little bit more
time to focus on cross validation
and you'll see here on this we have
our heroes talking about the sex we're
going to convert that to male 0
female 1. and then we'll do the same
thing with
marriage status at this point we're
going to create married status widow is
going to
if you're never married divorce
separated widow it's going to be zero
for single
and then we're going to put this as 1 if
you're married
and let's go ahead and convert this into
a type integer so this works really
nicely we'll have 0 and 1
for single or married and then there's
going to be an integer that way our
our different models can recognize it
most models don't recognize
text unless you encode it somehow just
real
quick before we start looping through
the different models
we've got to remember to create our y
which is going to be our income that's
our answer
and then of course from the data set
drop the y
because we don't want to use it as part
of the processing and the other thing we
want to look at
this is the code for creating our
x train y train x test y test
so normally a lot of times you'll see
this we just split the data
and we think okay good i've got my test
site i got my
y side but we're going to go ahead and
create a loop so that we can go through
this
and then take a look at that as far as
coming up with the results on there with
a cross validation
score so let's go ahead and run this
shoot
and uh whoops i must have mistyped
something all i need to do is uh rerun
the threads
because they'd run it twice and so it
didn't like changing things up when i'd
already
run it once and i've already made too
many changes on here
so we go ahead and run this and now we
have an x train and a y train
we're not actually going to do anything
with this x train and y train here this
is just a reminder for what that looks
like but we do need our data set
and our y part of the data set on here
so the next step this is the kind of
thing i love working with
is we create our models and you can see
where you can start creating really
robust packages to compare different
models
again remember we're dealing with small
data if you did this across big data you
can run into some major problems
and so we're going to import the two
different
data models logistic regression and k
neighbors classifier and we go ahead and
pin these both
to models on here and if we do something
like print
models we'll go ahead and run that
you can see that we have a title which
is a string and then
a function and we can run each of these
functions
going through our different setup
and then what we really want to do is we
want to
create a loop
for the different models and go through
the cross validation score on the
different models
and we'll go ahead and do i'm going to
create a results dictionary
one of my favorite things to do is put
everything in dictionaries
and we're going to go for name and model
in models
so for each row we have the name lr and
then the model is a logistic regression
model
and then we'll go ahead and do our k
fold right here this k
fold is the heart of the setup
on this i think the random state is
being
changed because it threw a warning on
there and how that's being done
we'll take a look at that in just a
second the warning and then we have our
splits we're doing 10 splits on here
with our k fold
uh and then we have our results and once
we have our results
which is going to be 10 we're going to
have a row of 10 pieces of data
from each different fold and so we want
to go ahead and do
the mean on that oops there we go go the
arrow the wrong way
and the standard deviation so how much
do they deviate from each other
how low is our error on here uh the
lower the better
so let's go ahead and run that and then
of course i have on mine
there we go we see down here is our
future warning
says something about random states i'm
not going to worry too much about that
that's warnings come up so often when
you're running these different
configurations because they're always
making changes on here
uh and so i've got in here my results
here's my results
um with the name and it's going to be
the means and the standard deviation on
here
oops there we go that way there's our
mean standard deviation
and then i always like to do key value
just because this reminds me very much
of doing mapping in larger data you
usually have a key value
for your setup and we'll print the key
value which in this case
is the name of the model and the results
on here
and we can see down here here's the two
models we ran
clearly i could add like a ton of these
different models
long as they are part of the sk learn
setup and they use the same
input there are some models that work
slightly differently so you don't want
to use
if you're doing classification and then
you switch to regression
you run into problems and of course
we're doing regression here
and we can see our results the knn
did slightly better it had lower errors
and look at the standard deviation the
standard deviation is also lower
so if i was running this model i would
go for
i'd be looking at the knn as my primary
model
i would then go re-run this model on all
the data
to send out for future predictions of
stuff we don't know
uh and you can see right here ahead you
know it does a nice job at
0.77 versus 0.79 and we'd pick this
you could run this across like i said a
lot of times there's like about six
seven different models in there some of
the models have different settings so
you might go in there and mess with the
settings
there's all kinds of ways to go through
this and then you can take your
in this case cross validation with in
this case uh
when we had 10 folds and you can get a
good idea of what kind of setup or which
model is going to work the best
and then compare it and then you go back
to your feedback loop of how to build it
and send it out
and of course from this definition this
uh model you have somebody new come in
and you find out what their marriage
status is their education
um this different information that we
put in here
you might find out how what their
predicted income is
yeah it worked pretty good i definitely
wouldn't
uh make it the primary goal with the
0.79 over here
error on there or with this kind of
setup on the means
but it would give you a good idea what
you're looking at for people coming in
if that's what you're trying to evaluate
so that wraps up our demo in this case
we're specifically looking at our k
folds uh we didn't get into looking at
the different columns and how to split
it but we did get into
going through different models and doing
a basic k-fold split on them and how
that works
thank you for joining us today at simply
learn for more information
please visit www www.simplylearn.com
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified click here